this weekend is Easter so you know what
that means
Christians everywhere will be setting
milk and cookies out for Jesus waiting
for him to return it either see a shadow
or declare that spring is here yeah I'm
a pretty religious guy but everywhere I
look the secularists are trying to take
the amen out of a man Erica so it's my
duty to call out these evil forces and
do what organized religions do best pass
judgment first up a development of
biblical proportions here at the Bible
Museum there are Bibles from presidents
Cleveland Truman Eisenhower George W
Bush and president Trump's inaugural
Bible was recently added to the
collection my mother gave me this Bible
this very Bible many years ago in fact
it's her writing right here she wrote
the name and my address and it's just
very special to me ah yes couch soldiers
president Trump's personal Bible is now
available to see at a museum and my
sources tell me that it's in mint
condition almost like he's never even
used it and just like the Jefferson
Bible I assume that the Trump Bible has
been edited down to the stories that he
finds most inspiring and relevant to him
like when Jesus went into the temple
found all the money changers and got a
great line of credit on a resurrection -
but don't listen to the haters who doubt
the president spicyness Trump is
obviously very religious because he has
access to a Bible that's why some of the
most religious figures in America our
bedside tables at La Quinta Inn so
what's my judgment of putting Trump's
Bible in a museum well that's a slice of
heaven on earth
[Music]
time to get a little thanks lord thank
you for honoring Trump's Bible and all
the words inside that he is definitely
read and for allowing another rich man
to inherit the earth as it should have
been written we'll keep fighting for you
Lord by fighting for President Trump
also please break Bob Buller stubbs amen
next an update on the strength of God's
army over the last five decades the
Catholic Church in the United States has
seen a steady decline in the number of
priests and sisters in 1965 there were
nearly fifty nine thousand priests in
the US and nearly a hundred and eighty
thousand religious sisters in 2016 the
numbers had dwindled to just over 37,000
priests and just over 47,000 sisters but
we're running out of priests and nuns we
started losing rabbis our bar jokes will
be decimated I don't get it why aren't
priests and nuns reproducing this is
scary stuff it could only mean one of
two things that the ideology and gender
hierarchy of the Catholic Church is
becoming increasingly anachronistic or
people don't find black slimming anymore
thankfully the nuns at the oblate
sisters of Providence convent have come
up with a surefire way to convince young
women to sign up for nun 'dom
challenging them to ask questions like
this do I want to marry Joe Blow or do I
want to marry Jesus Christ that's how
you make it an easy decision sister Joe
Blow or Jesus do I want to marry the guy
with the six-pack abs and the magic wine
fingers or do I want to change my last
name to blow
and those are your only two options lady
mr. blow or Jesus and Jill blows
probably already plowed his way through
half of OkCupid I mean we know that
so my judgment of all you children who
won't marry Jesus I cast thee to hell
time to chat hey Satan throw some more
sleeping bags on the brimstone these
kids are too good to get hitched to the
Lord above so they're just beggin to
suckle at your fiery teats let these
young demons with their secular
worldviews burn in your pits and leave
America to the saints like Trump and
Roseanne reverse amen my final judgement
tonight it's like this I'm like that and
like this and uh the d-o-double-g is
talking Geo single Dee you got that yeah
Snoop Dogg he's releasing some new music
a collection of gospel tracks the humble
peace loving family centered stoop
emerges on the 32 track double album
it's called Bible of love yes known
Trump hater and professional gin and
juicer Snoop Dogg has a gospel album
called Bible of love because I guess he
thinks he can beat the real Bible which
is already a Bible of love miracles and
how to properly clean your source
hey Leviticus you nasty opposition I'll
say it Snoop Doggy dog is not a real
religious er like me and Trump are
because just a few months ago he
released a whole album called make
America Crip again where he uses swear
words to talk about Donald Trump like a
sailor with rhythm and not the good kind
of sailors with rhythm either no laughs
let's see Snoop Dogg do that see that's
how you crip walk gated bell-bottoms no
less see snoop d-o-double-g you are not
forgiven and all of you pious pals out
there need to be warned that this album
has already hit number one on the iTunes
gospel charts pumping down
self-published gospel albums like my own
jesus wept
but I'm tough
hey snoop for this sham expression of
your renewed devotion to the most
original of G's I damn you to hell
yo Lucifer you need to punish this
rapper for disrespecting DT and pose it
as a false prophet don't set him on fire
because he loves smoking and lore forget
this new Pretender
but remember me because I'm crusading
out here for you every night and I have
a number of pending defamation lawsuits
where I could use a lot of help please
don't judge
[Music]